welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
Vinson and the Super Mario Bros movie
just came out and absolutely lived up to
his trailer hype there's no time to faff
about because this movie is packed and
we've got limited time to squeeze out
all the good good Mario juice out of it
Mario juice is extra pulpey by the way
to save time and effort I'll be saying
Bros instead of brothers and all the
titles for this video now let's dive
into that puppy Mario juice we have one
of the classic Fire versus Ice situation
as Bowser's airships fused lava onto the
ice below while menacingly making its
way towards the ice kingdom which is an
original Kingdom to the movie but the
Aurora Borealis and desolate Wasteland
Vibes are super reminiscent of the
Frosted Glacier world and new Super
Mario Bros U Deluxe as we get our first
good look at the ship the music playing
is called Bowser's airship theme
originating from Super Mario Bros 3. and
now's a good time to say that they used
so many songs from the games in this
movie that it would be impossible to
list them all in this video but I'll
toss in a few here and there then
Bowser's right-hand man throughout the
games comeback appears and you can see
some of the Koopas holding Flags which
are the flags of unbeaten levels in
several of the games when the Penguins
attack the red Koopa with eye patch
slips up and lifts it and shows that
it's a purely aesthetic eye patch gets
these days in their fashion man Bowser
steals what he later calls the Superstar
from this Kingdom indicating that while
stars are somewhat abundant in the Mario
games they are at the very least a
rarity in this universe we are then
treated to the piece of artwork that is
the Super Mario Bros Plumbing commercial
which is a song that originated from the
Super Mario Super Show during the
commercial the logo on the truck matches
the new Super Mario Bros Wii logo the
brothers are shown wearing yellow capes
which is an homage to the power you get
from the Cape Feather in Super Mario
World and also the phone number and
website listed are both real and the
website has tons of cute Easter eggs in
and of itself the commercial ants and
were shown the inside of punch out
Pizzeria a reference to the game punch
out which is appropriate seeing as the
walls are lined with Punch-Out
memorabilia including photos of several
of the punch-out boxers like glass Joe
Bear Hugger Little Mac and Doc and many
many more thrown in are also some
pictures of the NES game duck hunt which
there will be plenty more nods to later
the news report displays the headline
mayor Pauline has been re-elected
Pauline who we also see in a later news
report was first seen in the arcade game
Donkey Kong but later graduated to mayor
of New Dong City in Super Mario Odyssey
anyways Mario and Luigi debate over
whether or not their Italian Accents in
the commercial were too much when a
character Giuseppe dressed especially
like an older Mario says too much it's a
perfect I can't do the accent this
character is voiced by none other than
Charles martinet who is the original
voice actor for Mario in the games
Martinez also voices Mario's dad in the
movie which is a touching handoff
Giuseppe goes back to playing an arcade
cabinet that is meant to represent
Donkey Kong but is instead named Jump
Man which is what Mario's name was back
when Donkey Kong was released were then
introduced to spike Mario Luigi's former
manager who works at a company called
The Wrecking Crew but this isn't coming
out of thin air wrecking crew was an NES
game where Mario and Luigi worked on a
demolition team and a bearded Foreman
named Spike would try to disrupt the
brothers and make them fall can't blame
him for leaving a company where the boss
was actively trying to stop them from
doing their jobs Luigi gets a call and
we hear that his ringtone is the
GameCube starting screen sound and the
unknown caller picture is an outline of
the standard male Nintendo me character
as Mario and Luigi jump into the truck
next to the pizzeria is Sunshine Travel
Agency a reference to Super Mario
Sunshine in which Mario and Peach flew
to Isle Delfino which is shaped like a
dolphin as the truck stalls and they get
out to run we can see that their license
plate spells Mario Bros in the following
shots we get a couple of references to
the game Game and Watch first on the
truck behind them and then on a
construction sign when they're running
through the construction site it
switches to a 2d perspective like in the
original games and the entrance of the
construction site actually mimics level
1-1 of Super Mario Bros when Mario jumps
out of the pool and slides down in the
end the sound the goal pull makes in the
game plays and it is no coincidence that
burger Castle a red Castle shaped
building is right where the castle would
be at the end of the level the brothers
make it to their job and this luxury
apartment has more Easter eggs than
meets the eye the leftmost painting
looks suspiciously like Tetris blocks
and the paintings with blue and green
squares are very possibly referencing
some of the the background tiles from
Super Mario Bros 3. there's also a
painting at the end of the hall with the
dog from Duck Hunt another small detail
in the scene are the bottles in the
shower one says shine a reference to the
shine Sprites in Super Mario Sunshine
and I believe some of the others say
Zune which is the pseudonym of a
Japanese game developer who credits
Super Mario Bros as having a huge
influence on him cutting back to the
living room we see a couple more Easter
eggs with the Brooklyn Bridge and one
World Trade Center in the background a
glass statue out of a Pikmin and a book
the guy is reading called Galaxy with a
planet on it clearly a reference to
Super Mario Galaxy before we move on
there is so much in the human world that
Echoes what we see later in the Mushroom
Kingdom so let's do a speed round of
foreshadowing moments this small flag
figurine behind them that looks like a
green goal pull the gold star on this
kid's hat a Truck starting Montage which
is mirrored later with the carts green
grocery having fruit stands out front
and this cheeky sticker all the crates
and Scaffolding with green pipes
scattered throughout this picture of a
crown Mario hurtling and saying Mamma
Mia in slow motion and Luigi using the
mirror to push back against the water
stream much like in the final fight and
the Easter eggs don't stop as we head
back tomorrow in Luigi's house the coat
hooks they hang their hats on look like
little mushrooms and their house is
decked out and cozy and familial Decor
that starkly contrasts the modern
somewhat sterile Decor of the previous
scene the family leans heavily into
their Italian roots with red white and
green Walls a poster of the Leaning
Tower of Pisa and an Italian flag Banner
with a soccer ball on it there are also
trophies on the mantle for things like
bowling and racing and on the bookshelf
are figurines of sheep and sombreros a
nod to the Sheep In The Sand Kingdom of
Super Mario Odyssey the last Decor
detail in this room that I want to point
out is the base of their phone is
reminiscent of a Nintendo switch joy-con
next we move on to Mario's bedroom which
feels fast but hey Mario is playing Kid
Icarus on the NES and is clearly a
sports game fan looking at all the
posters and pictures around the room you
can see references to NES games golf
tennis NES pro wrestling featuring
Starman facing off against the Amazon
baseball Kung Fu and track and field he
also has a poster of f-zero and SNES
game and the polar bear from Ice
Climbers for the NES other gaming
references in his room include an r-wing
model from Star Fox a tennis racket
acknowledging his tennis Hobby and the
book The Odyssey on his headboard an
allusion to Super Mario Odyssey while
mayor Pauline is talking on the news the
scrolling headlines make reference to
the game wavery 64 and mentioned crabs
in the sewers likely pulling from the
Mario Bros arcade game in which Krabs
would come out of pipes in the sewers
running through the streets outside we
see a French restaurant called shasakana
which is duck hunt in French as the
brothers go into the sewer and break
through the wall the hole they make is
in the shape of an 8-bit Mario head as
they walk down the staircase a Simon
Says level 1 2 is on the wall
referencing level one two of Super Mario
Bros in which they are underground and
fittingly the underground theme song
plays Mario bursts out of a pipe
stemming from an archway the red brick
perfectly merging the world he came from
with the Mushroom Kingdom where red
bricks are a bit more emblematic and
thank you to betterhelp for sponsoring
this video movies and TV can mean great
escapism but when it's time to face
things head on betterhelp is here to
help better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it is 100 online
with better help you can tap into a
network of over 25
000 licensed and experienced therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues to get started just answer a few
questions about what you're looking for
from therapy and what your preferences
are better health will then match you
with a therapist from their Network
that's right for you after that talk to
your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether it's via text chat
phone or video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge Better
Health gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy Toad's backpack is full of
adventuring gear making fans speculate
that he might be the future Captain Toad
from previous Mario games his bag also
has decorative pins that show Princess
Peach's castle the upside on Pyramid in
the sand Kingdom from Mario Odyssey and
the dinosaur from Cascade Kingdom of the
same game toad says that Mario's brother
has landed in the dark lands darkland
also being the final world of Super
Mario Bros 3 where Bowser's main Castle
stands and when Mario gets a look at the
castle and surrounding land for the
first time inside the castle walls from
Super Mario 64 plays we also see several
dome-like rock formations which is
referencing the capsule-shaped hills
seen in the background of many Mario
games Luigi unfortunately isn't having
as good of a time but one fun fact is
that when he hits the dry bones a Sting
from The Fortress theme from Super Mario
Bros 3 plays and in that same scene
you'll get a taste of the Luigi's
Mansion theme then we make it to toad
town which I'm referring to as toad town
because pretty consistently throughout
the games the town right outside of
Peach's castle is called toad town and
the Lamppost and Crown coloring is the
same as paper Mario's toad town so there
now please allow me to be your personal
tour guide for toad town I will hold the
dinging of the miscible details till the
end so you don't go mad the most
prominent Foods you'll find in toad town
are fruits that are straight out of
Super Mario Sunshine as well as Yoshi's
story and sweets possibly because of the
various dessert themed levels featured
throughout the series and if all that
Sugar from fruits and desserts don't
give you Toad levels of energy don't
worry because there were coffee shops
everywhere admire the Fountain of four
cheap cheaps stop by the pie shop the
fish shop the ATMs with the treasure
chest symbol from Super Mario Bros 3
over them the weapon shop the crazy cat
store from Super Mario Odyssey the shop
with a power Barrel this shop with what
looks to be maybe turnips and radishes
from Super Mario Bros 2. the antique
shop the what you want to know what's in
the antique shop
okay you got access from Super Mario
Bros and an open time that looks like
the title screen a dragon coin from
Super Mario World Treasure Chest from
Super Mario Bros 3 he's from a few of
the Mario games a pixelated version of a
super Bell a boomerang flower an NES
cartridge the toad is holding that the
shopkeeper says he has to blow into does
this thing work
s
referencing how is a popular Theory back
in the day that if a game cartridge
wasn't working you should blow into it
to get it to work again a chest full of
coins a hammer from Super Mario Bros 3 a
sign with the coin cost of a Tanooki
Suit a mushroom and a super Leaf a
poster of the end of world 1 3 of Super
Mario Bros a pow block or maybe a school
box from Super Mario World hard to tell
exclamation blocks possibly a mannequin
hand holding a warp whistle from Super
Mario Bros 3. more stickers on the Shelf
in the middle that depict more Super
Mario Bros scenes magic potions from
Super Mario Bros 2 a music box from
Super Mario Bros 3 a Yoshi a Glam a
poster of Princess Peach from her
letters in Super Mario Bros 3 p wings
from the same game p balloons from Super
Mario World Peace switches and clouds
from Super Mario Bros 3 Springs from
Super Mario Bros the Lost Levels and
anchors from Super Mario Bros 3. other
toe town must-sees are a poster of a
band with Toadette in it a purple toad
named chanterelle which is the same name
of the singer in club 64 in Paper Mario
and a chief chief that gives Mario a
death player seemingly joking that
enemies just naturally have something
against Mario check out our Builder
toads first seen in Super Mario Maker a
map of the Mushroom Kingdom and a Super
Mario World world map style and a map in
the style of Super Mario Bros 3 as you
can tell by the coin checkpoints alright
tour's over that's 47 missable details
for toe town and Mario runs off the
platform in the same distinctive way he
runs in Super Mario 3D World 48. now
like I said the number of songs from the
game in this movie soundtrack is wild
but this particular scene has an insane
number of songs the only one I'll take
the time to call out is an extremely
subtle line of the underwater theme from
Super Mario Bros that plays on the cheap
cheap mean mugs Mario
for the rest of the songs and sound
effects in the scene you'll have to
check out my breakdown of when this clip
came out we've got to get to the castle
at the castle Gates the toad guards tell
Mario that the princess is in another
Castle a throwback to the famous land
from Super Mario Bros the throne room of
the castle is most similar to Mario
Odyssey and its layout and the main
stained glass installation is the exact
same design as the one in Odyssey some
details here the cloud design and the
stained glass Sun detailing on the floor
and checkered pattern on the floor are
seen in several of the games the
candelabras have bulbs that have the
slight shape of the original fire
flowers and throughout the castle are
paintings that have adventuring toads
scattered throughout them peaches toad
Council gathers around an interactive
map and we can see all the lands that
they end up traveling through plus an
island that looks like an N64 controller
Peach decides to go to the Jungle
Kingdom I'm calling it Donkey Kong
Country huh but first the training
grounds few quick fun details here the
flagpole is styled after the Gold pole
design originally from new Super Mario
Bros how when Peach reaches the goal the
signature sound plays foreign
she then floats down with her dress and
while in earlier game she was able to
hover without an umbrella Super Mario 3D
World was the first game where she used
her dress to float like this the lights
around the starting platform resemble
the super crowns from new Super Mario
Bros U Deluxe and this fish is me at 3am
riding this breakdown on to Bowser's
Castle the troops are partying it up and
among them are Koopas paratroopa swoops
piranha plants Dry Bones Shy Guy sniff
at spinies but bombs Goombas Hammer Bros
Sledge Bros Buzzy beetles and chain
Chomps there's a band of Koopas with
their faces painted to possibly pay
homage to kiss but also look like
they're painted to look like dry bones
Bowser is notoriously self-obsessed and
his throne being literally him sitting
proves this point we cut back to Luigi
and are treated to a flashback featuring
Baby Mario and Luigi with notably some
turtles in the background Baby Mario
Luigi were both first seen in Yoshi's
Island and Baby Peach debuted later in
Mario and Luigi partners in Time
meanwhile Mario Peach and Toad leave the
castle and we get a travel Montage they
first cross a field representing Bob on
Battlefield from Superman Mario 64 with
the cannon surrounded by rocks a wooden
ramp with a box by it and a floating
island with a tree then they cross a
bridge with cheap tubes flying at them
likely an Ode to the cheap cheap bridge
in World 2-3 of Super Mario Brothers 4
world 6 1 of Super Mario 3D Land then
there's a desert that appears to be
influenced by the sand Kingdom from
Super Mario Odyssey judging by the
upside down floating pyramid Islands
half buried pillars with vibrant colors
like toasterina town and cacti we get
just a tease of Yoshi's Island that
looks a lot like new Yoshi's Island and
the Yoshi Village from Paper Mario where
Mario eats an apple notoriously Yoshi's
favorite fruit and finally they end up
on the Cliffside set distinctly resemble
the rock structures from rock candy
mines in new Super Mario Bros U we then
get treated to a Bowser solo called
peaches that was maybe unsurprisingly
written by Jack Black along with
directors Aaron Horvath and Michael
jelinek and editor an additional voice
actor Eric Osmond fun fact John Spiker
who plays bass for Tenacious D played
the piano for peaches and when Bowser
and camac jammed together they play the
underground theme again cutting back to
the trio in a field of fire flowers
Mario take takes office had to talk
about how worried he is about his
brother while in a few of the games
Mario is physically more vulnerable when
he doesn't have his hat via taking more
damage he is emotionally more vulnerable
when his hat is off here Peach gains the
fire flower power up and her dress
changes to her fire Peach dress seen in
the games and in response to Mario
suggesting she's from his World peach
says it's a huge Universe out there with
a lot of galaxies teasing a potential
Mario Galaxy sequel in the future
speaking of Galaxy we then meet an
adorably nihilistic Luma that we can
actually tell is illumalee by its light
blue color and the little cowlick at the
top of its head how it got here is a
mystery but where illumily is Rosalina
can be far behind but for now the trio
arrive at the jungle Kingdom as they
stir up at the entrance that is straight
out of Donkey Kong Country Returns DK
Island swing from the first level of
Donkey Kong Country Place the memories
they take off towards the throne room in
a cart that has a rhino on the front a
reference to rammy the Rhino from the
Donkey Kong series they use the cart
glider that first appeared in Mario Kart
7 to fly into a temple styled after the
golden temple from Donkey Kong Country
Returns we then find out from Cranky
Kong That Donkey Kong is his son which
switches up the family tree a bit since
in the games Donkey Kong would be his
grandson but he's also a freaking King
now so in the hallway when Mario is
about to enter the ring is a training
dummy that looks like a naughty from
Donkey Kong Country and the stadium
itself is decked out in red scaffolding
blue letters and barrels just like the
original Donkey Kong which is fitting
because Cranky Kong is canonically the
original Donkey Kong from that game the
absolutely Flawless DK rap from Donkey
Kong 64 plays as Donkey Kong enters the
arena and we see the Dixie ditty and
chunky konger in the audience DK says
it's on like Donkey Kong a line
originally from a song by Ice Cube but
now trademarked by Nintendo as DK beats
Mario's mushrooms to a pulp the side
shot we get almost mimics the 2D view of
Super Smash Bros and speaking of now
would be a good time to point out that
this movie has stayed faithful to a lot
of the characters game moves Donkey
Kong's rule attack cat Mario's diving
attack Mario's jumping punch pose
they're too many to list but they did an
amazing job and the same goes for
Mario's class classic Expressions there
are so many mario-isms that Mamma Mia's
it's
amazing very good Peach and Mario talk
outside a hut that is almost identical
to the Kong tree house and Donkey Kong
Country Returns and there's a rocking
chair outside as a nod to cranky Kong's
rocking chair in the games inside
there's a world map in the style of
Super Mario World along with several
pictures and posters of different cart
mechanics and trophies and a picture of
Funky Kong surfing they then head to the
cart Warehouse where one of the
mechanics has a 64 on a shirt perhaps a
reference to Diddy Kong Racing 64. we
can also see some banana barrels from
Mario Kart tour installed into the carts
that are utilized later the trio go to
their cart making stations with card
selectors straight out of Mario Kart 8.
Mario gets a version of his standard
card from Mario Kart Wii Peach gets a
bike most similar to her mock bike and
has changed into her killer Mario Kart
biker outfit toad is rocking a monster
truck most similar to the Tiny Titan and
DK is driving a cart that vaguely
resembles the bolt buggy from Mario Kart
7 with rocket barrels from DK Country
Returns attached Mario and dkd actually
later ride the this Barrel through the
sky the same way it's used in the game
with NC Bowser rehearsing his wedding
and part of what we later see is his
full wedding attire from Super Mario
Odyssey and he holds the same bouquet of
lilies and piranha plants that peach had
in the same game he's practicing with
comic dressed as Peach which oddly
enough isn't the first time seeing his
comic also dressed as peach in New Super
Mario Bros Wii honestly I don't know
what's going on here but I support it
then we're gracefully given a beautiful
and action-packed rainbow rose scene
Rainbow Road being the most famous
course in the Mario Kart series The
Classic theme plays as they drive down
the path and several details from the
game are displayed during their race
with a Koopas as Mario drifts the Sparks
from his cargo from Blue to Orange to
purple which in the games represent the
size of the Boost you get from drifting
the tires turning sideways for
anti-gravity mode was introduced in
Mario Kart 8 and we also got a haha here
marioisms the blue Koopa turns into a
spiny shell an Infamous item from the
Mario Kart games that targets players in
first place it also does a couple little
circles around the Target and then blows
up like it does in the later games but
things go so well and Mario and DK gets
swallowed by Amari that is specifically
modeled after the Mario Odyssey version
later as Peach approaches Bowser's
airship we see super Bell trees from
Super Mario 3D World and the flowers
that are adorably planted in little red
brick blocks when telling Peach about
the Star Bowser says we will be
Invincible which clearly has a double
meaning here we get to the wedding and
King babam and King Boo from Super Mario
64 are both on the guest list Peach
wears a wedding dress similar to her one
in Odyssey with an added peachy color at
the bottom at the same time DK and Mario
team up to fight their way towards the
wedding and as it enters the side
scroller view we get about 8 million
more songs and moves straight out of the
games the way Mario runs with his arms
out him hitting the blocks underneath
enemies Donkey Kong's Forward Air Attack
Mario's ground pound and if we look in
the background we can see a shop sign
that has the same Super Mario 3 Treasure
Chest symbol that was over at the ATMs
earlier Mario transforms into Tanooki
Mario first seen in Super Mario Bros 3
and takes to the skies eventually the
fight is taken to the human world where
we see even more Easter eggs around the
city there's a 24-hour Car Wash sign
with a character from the arcade and NES
game balloon fight there's also an
electronic repair shop called disc
hardware company which is a reference to
discu and the mascot for the famicom
disc system in Japan you can even see
his outline on the left of the sign we
can see an ad for luck cards which bear
almost the same symbol AS Spade panels
from Super Mario Bros 3 in which you
played a bonus game where you had to
match cards in the same shot you can see
the ad on top of the taxi says save the
kingdom and the subliminal messaging
doesn't stop there when Mario's beaten
down and sitting in front of the broken
television the Jumpman cabinet by his
side says help me but the tides change
and Mario Luigi get the Superstar
obtaining the same rainbow effect the
star would give you in many of the games
and the invincibility star theme is
heard and if you didn't stick around
there are two post-credits scenes the
first features Bowser singing or reprise
to peaches now held in a Cajun Peach's
castle and the second revealing a
cracking Yoshi egg that's in the same
sewers as the beginning of the movie
solidifying that Yoshi will indeed be in
the next movie and then my friends is
what we could find from our initial
viewings of the movie I personally can't
wait for a sequel and I'm still crossing
my fingers that will get a Galaxy plot
line in the second one what would y'all
want to see in a sequel leave it in the
comments until then you can follow me on
Twitter at it's annavanston and follow
And subscribe to new rockstars at new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love
time
Donkey Kong
is here
[Music]
foreign